AMERICA'S PRIVACY WAS VIOLATED
BY JEFF BEZOSES  ON.
THINK BEING IT A LOT.
SO THAT WAS THE FIRST THING, I
MEANT TO SAY CLEARLY, I TOTALLY
DISAPPROVE OF WHAT THE NATIONAL
ENQUIRER DID TO JEFF BEZOSES
ON.
I D. BUT IT DOES RAISE THE
QUESTION, WHAT IS AMAZON DOING
TO THE REST OF US.
>> YES, I WISH WE WERE A SOCIETY
THAT HAD NO INTEREST.
AND LET THAT BE BETWEEN THE
SPOUSES.
BUT THAT'S ALL THE REASON WHY WE
SHOULD VALUE PRIVACY.
I SPENT A LOT OF YEARS AS A
JOURNALIST, DEFENDING  THAT
VALUE AND ONE OF THE COMPANIES
THAT POSES THE GREATEST THREAT
TO IT IS AMAZON.
IT'S A MAJOR SOURCE OF JEFF
BEZOS OS'S WEALTH AND POWER, AND
YOU KNOW, WE THINK OF AMAZON AND
DO THEIR BRANDING, THAT IS A
PLACE WE BUY OUR BOOKS FROM.
AND DOWNLOAD E-MAIL FROM.
IN FACT, THE MAIN BUSINESS IS
WORKING WITH THE SECURITY
STRAIGHT AGENCIES TO BUILD HUGE
APPARATUSES OF THE SURVEILLANCE
STATE THAT INVADE OUR PRIVACY IN
WAYS FAR MORE SEVERE THAN WHAT
THE NATIONAL ENQUIRER DID TO
JEFF BEZOSES  ON.  AND THAT'S A
PART OF THE STORY THAT IS SO
IRONIC, BEYOND THE FACT THAT
AMAZON IS NOTORIOUS FOR ABUSING
ITS WORKERS AND ALL THAT PEOPLE
YOU JUST NAMED, YOU WOULD FIND
QUITE UPSETTING.
SO WILL YOU QUICKLY SUMMARIZE A
BIG PART OF THEIR BUSINESS IS
NOT SELLING TOOTHPASTE, WHICH IS
WHAT I USE IT FOR, BUT HELPING
THE NATIONAL SECURITY STATE,
GATHER INFORMATION ON CITIZENS.
>> AMAZON HAD A $500 MILLION
CONTRACT WITH THE C.I.A. TO
PROVIDE CLOUD SERVICES.
THEY ARE NOW USING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO BUILD A PRODUCT
CALLED "RECOGNITION" THAT'S
DESIGNED TO USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE TO IDENTIFY
BY THE THOUSANDS, SO WHEREVER
YOU GO, YOU CAN BE IDENTIFIED BY
SOFTWARE THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
USING.
THAT AMAZON IS AGO.
THEY ARE USING SECURITY SYSTEMS
AROUND PEOPLE'S PERIMETERS OF
THEIR HOUSES  AND MAKING IT
AVAILABLE SO THEY CAN SEE WHO'S
COMING  AND LEAVING YOUR HOUSE,
WHO'S INSIDE OF YOUR HOUSE.
BUT LET'S GO ON AND ON OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT AMAZON IS BUILDING
AND PROFITING FROM, WAY MORE
THAN BOOKS, THAT ARE DIRECT REPS
TO OUR PRIVACY AND CRITICAL
COMTONIGHTS.
92 WHY DO I NEVER READ THAT
STORY?
>> BECAUSE SILICON VALLEY IS
MORE POWERFUL IN WASHINGTON THAN
WALL STREET IS.
IT'S BECAUSE SILICON VALLEY NOW
CONTROLS HUGE PARTS OF THE MEDIA
AND THE LAST THING PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA WANT TO DO IS COVER
SILICON VALLEY CRITICALLY.
SO THE POWER OF GOOGLE AND
FACEBOOK AND AMAZON IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
STORIES IN THE WORLD AND ALSO
ONE OF THE MOST UNDERCOVER